No.
There's so many artists out there all
over the world that are making art
really.
I know this sounds idealistic really
because they're artists and they just
have to make things and they come
through the art schools where they don't
go to art schools and maybe they are
influenced by a trend or a theory.
Maybe they even want to make money from
art,
but they're making art.
I've never really met that many people
that make our just to make money.
There's so many other ways to make
money.
This is said with investing in the end,
to hear about these people that want to
make money from investing.
You can make so much more money
investing the traditional ways then you
can from investing in art that there's
certain,
a certain mythology about that.
Even though,
yes,
of course some people have made money
from buying art.